thank you maurice very much
yes i'm here with world number two
fabiano caruana
after uh a devastating victory for uh
him
fabiano welcome to the show uh welcome
back to bucharest
how does it feel to be back uh in the
circuit in the grand chester
circuit it feels good to be playing over
the board uh and with less pressure than
the candidates so more
let's say a more normal tournament uh it
feels like
like some sort of familiarity you know
which is nice uh you also played in the
candidates as you mentioned do you feel
you have an advantage over the players
that let's say have been a little bit
less
active throughout the pandemic yeah
possibly
but a lot of players played in the
candidates here um so besides me there's
three
three others yeah um
so yeah it's it's not like it's not like
everyone's been out of practice
there are players who haven't played for
over a year like i think wesley last
played in
uh you know like a year and a half ago
so it's been it's been a long break over
the board for some players but uh
or others have a bit more practice from
your perspective we were talking with
leveroni and he was mentioning that
opening preparation usually doesn't
translate very well into the rapid
events
uh and now he's trying to catch up on
the opening preparation
how was your training regimen going into
this
tournament yeah i was able to do some
work and
and have a chance to relax after the
candidate so i had like a month off so i
i worked i didn't do like very specific
prep for this tournament um
but i feel like i'm you know i'm ready
opening wise and hopefully also in terms
of
of my form in terms of how i play um it
was nice at least to get a break you
know before after the candidates
cool let's uh go into this game and he
did he surprised you with the move e6
with the french or
were you ready for this i can't say that
i was surprised because uh
like i don't have any really recent
games from him especially over the board
he hasn't played in a long time
he played um i think the european
qualifying event for the world cup
and he played the sicilian never game
there but i somehow didn't really expect
the sicilian because uh
it's it's like the line he plays where
the rouser is extremely
dangerous um and he was probably worried
that uh
that you know he could run into some
preparation or or get a bad position
and the french's is a much safer opening
um and i think he was well prepared
like did he surprise you with this move
knight bd7 or uh
well in the past when he got this
position he had he played 97 i think
both
moves are are extremely popular i'm not
even sure which is more popular
hp7 or 97 um and and it's clear that he
had prepared
this line because he played quickly like
up to this point up to africa
and then he started thinking here um but
it
but uh i realized that he had uh he had
some knowledge of the position at least
and um
and we were both more or less on our own
after rook d8 i think
this is like more or less when i started
to think but but my moves were kind of
simple because i only have one idea in
this position which is to
mate him with bishop c2 queen e4 and and
try to get queen h7
um and where did you feel he lost the
plot
well there was so bishop a4 surprised me
i realized it was a move but i really
expected the e5
um and i think that he was afraid of
of this so it looks super dangerous
because i'm
trying queen e7 and gf7 and rook h6 but
he can actually solve
a lot of those issues with the move
queen g5 which i think is only move
i was trying to figure this position out
over the board but i actually didn't
really want to go for this
um so you saw this move queen g5 yeah i
saw this and this is the reason why i
was thinking about other moves here
um but i didn't see anything which
really
made me happy uh yeah so after queen g5
i was thinking of
a few moves one was okay f4 i thought
was the safest move
because if queen of six and rook h6 is
coming this is very bad uh
he can't allow rook h6 so after f4 he
has to go for queen g6
queen e7 bishop f5 is very fortunate for
him that he has this otherwise
uh his position falls apart so i have to
take king a1
and now dc isn't possible so he has two
moves i thought i mean maybe there's
another one
rookie eight actually i thought this was
very nice that
i'm sorry um if
if uh rook d7 i thought it was actually
very nice i could play queen h2
but now i realize that my calculations
roll off i thought i would have like
queen h6 because actually
the king on b2 it's very hard for him to
check it but he can take on d1 and i
don't have an attack
um so yeah i this probably was leading
into equality and
and maybe i would have to find a
different move after e5
uh but it's not easy to find moves
because like knight of three he has
bishop c6
or maybe there's another move as well
and and he gets g2 in the end
um actually he's seems to be better at
this point
well maybe maybe i shouldn't take only
five um but but anyway like a knight of
three i really didn't want to play
because it
it's clear that like my knight on d4 is
controlling his lightsaber bishop
so my whole idea is that i want to
attack him before he can
like say harass my queen um so yeah this
this
i was worried about i was very happy
when he went for this um
and and yeah this was the last one i
thought maybe this but it doesn't really
seem great because i can play this he
has to like run away
and i can keep harassing his queen and
he keeps running away but it
it doesn't feel like i also have um
i'll go back you're uh you're a pawn up
and it seems like your knight will
actually control
your defense on this side yeah it is
kind of concrete because if i
if he gets like rook v8 and i'm forced
to play knight b3
then it'll be hard for me to untangle
but i have some annoying stuff like this
because he can't take because of rook d4
so he has to go back and and my knight
sort of stays active like knight c6 is a
possibility
um but yeah after this i actually
like didn't see it's kind of important
that here he gets pinned
and i think it is very important that
there's a knight there's queen d3 king
c1 otherwise like king a1i lose yeah
yeah queen evil so but but these lines
weren't too
difficult to figure out and this
position is just very very saturated
because he can't
move any pieces well a pretty decent
start for you how do you feel about your
chances uh
in this tournament so far so good uh
first two rounds i couldn't have um
really hoped for more so it's a good
start but it's a long tournament and
i think we're going to see like some
players are a bit cautious now but i
think at some point we'll see
players taking risks and a lot of
decisive results awesome great to see
you
on fire after this game we're looking
forward to the rest of
your games hi guys back to you thank you
christian